i'm laura ingram this is ingram angle
from washington tonight thanks for being
with us
the real terrorists that's the focus of
tonight's angle
right the democrats had their narrative
set rise long before biden was sworn
into office
theirs wasn't a story about how
americans would thrive or be safe and
happy under the biden's policies
no because their climate change
obsession would deeply damage american
families they always knew that
therefore as kind of a preemptive
measure they decided to argue the
negative
that electing republicans in the future
would be akin to electing terrorists who
would seek to blow up our entire system
this is just an
extraordinarily dangerous of course for
republicans to be taking in terms of our
democracy the republican party can no
longer say that they don't agree with
the insurrectionists with the bigots
with the racist there may now be people
aligned with white supremacists who are
in congress how do you protect the
country from them
it could be that we have a republican
majority in congress this fall and if
that happens you may see republicans in
congress wanting to cut the money to the
department of justice to turn the lights
out we may
lose our democracy
the attorney general issued ominous
warnings
the top domestic violent extremist
threat comes from racially or ethnically
motivated violent extremists
specifically those who advocated for the
superiority of the white race
they announced new task forces
i've decided to establish a domestic
terrorism unit
to augment our existing approach
this group of dedicated attorneys will
focus on the domestic terrorism threat
and of course especially after january 6
the media
never looked back so chicago could
remain a killing field more than 100 000
americans could die from overdoses china
could plot against us in the asian
pacific and instead of covering any of
that as it needs to be covered the press
focused almost singularly on vilifying
the conservative movement with
groundless smears about an insurrection
that wasn't
and with the wheels coming off the
democratic party because you know look
because of our crumbling economy
the january 6th meth is still all
they've got
this week's hearing the january 6th
hearing which
surely are the most important hearings
since watergate these hearings are going
to be quite compelling i think they
understand the importance of leveraging
live television
to to convince the american public about
how serious this was we have
this committee investigation coming up
which again if you really love america
if you believe in american democracy if
you're a patriot you want to know what
happened on january 6th
oh joe tell us about it now first off on
its face these allegations are ludicrous
the idea that that ragtag group of
people who smashed their way into the
capitol that they were the product of
some organized effort orchestrated out
of the west wing it's beyond ridiculous
if there was true evidence of any of
that we have already heard about it
now the moment i saw what was happening
on capitol hill i texted mark meadows
the chief of staff of the white house i
told him to ask the president to tell
everyone to go home i think i was the
first person to do that maybe one of the
first i knew it was going to hurt the
cause and i said the same thing publicly
on twitter throughout the afternoon and
that night on the angle
now it was obvious a group of angry
people had whipped up the crowd into a
frenzy and that's when things became
violent
now we've always said
that in any case when laws are broken
perpetrators need to be punished justice
must be done without regard to politics
but that wasn't enough for the democrats
they have attempted unsuccessfully to
use january 6
to indict the entire republican party
and protect themselves
in other words to insulate themselves
from any accountability for the
devastation they're currently wreaking
upon america
indeed it is the democrats and their far
left base that have been the ones
terrorizing america these past few years
now we're never going to forget the
wildings that masqueraded as protests
[Applause]
wow
[Applause]
can you believe that was america
and then of course antifa attacking
citizen journalists
[Applause]
[Applause]
then there was blm harassing innocent
americans
abortion fanatics besieging the homes of
supreme court justices
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
showing up at joel osteen's lakewood
church in texas
it's my body
my
choice
and if that underwear wasn't enough to
terrify you they're upping the ante by
vandalizing the crisis pregnancy centers
around the country it started about a
month ago in madison wisconsin
we're investigating the fruits and
of hate and violence in the form of an
arson
where a specific non-profit group was
targeted for their beliefs regarding the
issue of abortion
and it continues to this day this past
weekend a pregnancy crisis center in
washington dc's capitol hill
neighborhood was vandalized with red
paint eggs in a message reading
jane says revenge
in amherst new york yesterday more acts
of terror compass care pregnancy
services clinic had its windows broken
it was graffitied and set on fire
police are investigating it as arson
jane's revenge is this group that's
attempting
to to to strike fear into the hearts of
pro-life service organizations to keep
them
from providing care the intent was for
compass care to stop services we won't
stop
and when police officers in asheville
north carolina called my next guest
christy brown the executive director of
mountain area pregnancy services to tell
her that the clinic she runs had been
vandalized they warned her
that it was bad
when she got to the door of her clinic
this morning she found threatening
messages sprayed in red paint on three
sides of the building and the sidewalk
as well was broken with windows painted
on the property where the is if
abortions aren't safe
neither are you
we'll show that picture in a moment now
understand
these homes are often run by volunteers
most of them are
who selflessly try to assist unwed
oftentimes scared expectant mothers
these crisis pregnancy centers offer
young women hope and compassion when
they need it most
so think of how sick those are who
threaten the sanctuary
how was any of this not a hate crime
where are the congressional hearings
the capitol hill press conferences
condemning the hate groups behind these
threats
we know the answer
if you're pro-life democrats really
don't think you deserve to be protected
from hate in fact
you deserve hate
once again the democrats have gone so
far left they've left america
none of this is going to break through i
don't think or make the slightest
difference in november
most regular people i don't know i'm
getting the sense that they see january
6 as an awful aberration
not as the event that defines america or
the republican party
but democrats and their media minions
they're going full steam ahead
they're hoping for a runaway summer
blockbuster
the definition of out of touch should
include blowing countless millions of
taxpayer dollars on partisan hearings
when american moms still can't find baby
formula
so the real terrorists are those seeking
to overthrow every american tradition
from the apolitical nature of the
supreme court to the sanctity of
churches
and they're not doing it through
democratic processes but through
intimidation
threats and yes
even violence
that's the angle hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else